following the film last week like my
friends who saw it at the same time one
of the things they were talking about
was that scene where you pulled down a
helicopter I don't know the shape of
your arms in particular yeah a little
bit of bicep tolerance then was it more
than the China how what was it how hard
is it to the liner I missed it
how hard is it to look like much oh I
don't think it was Kevin did you oh
that's all right I think I think it was
me but it's you know you do those things
luckily between scheduling and Russa
everyone you try and get those scenes as
early on and in filming as possible
because you you gradually shed weight as
you're filming you wear in that suit
every day and you just I was helping him
work on his shoulder about six weeks
after that I I really genuinely did mess
up something in my arm or we love that
shot doing it you know like it's a very
unnatural position to be in and you're
like look you're trying to flex you're
trying to look good on that like you
know madness it's not a utilitarian shot
you it's really just trying to look good
yeah that come on in I was just dumped
Oh what do you want I was gonna say um
you really were holding back a
helicopter - it was on a rig clearly but
the first take we did rig it it didn't
go far enough and so you're kind of just
you look silly almost and you say guys
you gotta can we get it so it actually
extends to the point where you really
are trying to hold something and they
did and you really do all of a sudden
you are trying to hold something may not
be a helicopter but regardless it it did
something and that's true they were
there were many days that I would come
into Downey's trailer and he has all
these amazing contraptions he's like
well I was gonna say another comic book
character we don't want to bring DC into
this but he has all these amazing toys
and uh and and he really had all these
little will you know stickers and weird
things and like electro medicine
whatever it is and it actually was great
it's a mess again though I'll mention
this I remember the day we shot that
scene there was a miscommunication with
costume department and
first came the set to start the scene in
a jacket and Joe and I were like no no
no no it would've been a different scene
yeah jacket look onset physio mr. Don
jr. like that no sight place that's nice
you Robert thanks Jeremy rubbing down
Chris that's sweet little digital
stimulation never had anybody
we're telling which would be really ugly
Joe get along
you